the omicron variant prompting some
changes for international travel people
flying to the united states must now get
tested for covid19 within a day of
boarding a plane joe mohler live at
mccarran airport now with those
additional details joe
brian these changes started today
anybody flying here into mccarran today
had to get a copin 19 test within the
past day now these are for international
flights we caught up with people who
were arriving from mexico city today
many say they didn't mind and they did
notice that some people at the airport
there did not know about these changes
i think it's okay people flying to las
vegas from mexico city monday night were
some of the first to experience new
travel changes
well i think that it's extremely
important to fly into the united states
travelers must get tested for the virus
a day ahead of departure negative
results must be shown before takeoff at
the counter during check-in and before
you
you board the plane the goal was to add
a layer of protection as the omicron
variant continues to be a concern the
changes apply to everyone regardless of
vaccination status claudia lopez did not
mind it's a
prevention measure
and i think that 24 hours it's okay she
says some were not aware and there was
confusion at the airport in mexico some
people did not know about the new
measures daniel davila says their
airline informed them of the changes he
says airport officials were taking it
seriously there was a guy that he didn't
brought his kobe vaccine test and he got
rejected
just like that according to the cdc you
can also show documentation that you
have recovered from coping 19 in the
past 90 days these changes apply to
anyone over the age of two we are using
masks but
it's we don't know who has coped vaccine
and it's just so dangerous
now back here out here live in case you
were wondering it doesn't need to be
exactly 24 hours a test just needs to be
done the day before near to party
reporting live at mccarran international
airport this evening joe mohler live
local now